to politics now and another sign of  transition today president-elect  joe biden starts getting the same delhi  intelligence briefings as president  donald trump  meanwhile biden has also announced his  nomination for treasury secretary  it is former federal reserve chair janet  yellen if confirmed  she'd be the first woman to lead that  department president-elect biden also  plans to nominate two women of color to  key  economic roles over the weekend  president trump meanwhile gave his first  interview since losing the election  and he repeated unsubstantiated claims  of election fraud and even questioned  the justice department  this is total fraud and how the fbi and  department of justice i don't know maybe  they're involved  president-elect biden is moving ahead he  also injured his foot over the weekend  he was playing with his dog at the time